hello reject nation
Craig Albee here and I shot first
alright so John and I we're on our
second shot second trailer of the
Superbowl here I thought this trailer
was coming out tomorrow maybe it's just
a tease for tomorrow of 45 second tease
solo a Star Wars story this is what I've
been waiting for a movie I have insane
amounts of doubt about hit that dislike
button people I know it's coming cuz I
said it's all engagements yeah it's all
engagement but hey I'm gonna keep an
open mind you know this movie comes out
in a couple months
we'd phil lord chris miller and ron
howard how could you not be excited oh
gosh alright let's say Rishon all of it
nine days actually nervous to watch this
[ __ ] let's watch it
trust me you're gonna love it
interesting
which brings you interested in joining
the best I got
[Music]
cool
[Music]
like Monica crashes in the second whoa
there is Lando
[Music]
Hey so it is tomorrow the official
trailer the wage shot looks really cool
the production design looks like
everything we expect from a Star Wars
movie to look good looks good but there
seems to be a little bit of a grittier
aesthetic than I was expecting it to
look like yeah especially knowing Phil
Lord and Chris Miller did the original
shoots on it and then I know Ron Howard
did a lot of reshoots on it it looks
different and it looks like they have
something to add and even though that it
was just the back of chewy he looks like
a younger chewy yeah he's a young buck
still but even though it is Star Wars
it's familiar in a design kind of way it
also looks like it's adding to the
cannon and again just this the montage
they've laid out here actually pulled me
in so much more than I was examine ufff
to make me go
all right I'm definitely gonna go watch
this movie really surprises I've had so
much doubt against it Greg there's not
much to go off of but in terms of tone
style the way the actors look in it this
looks like it could be a really kick-ass
movie and it's interesting because road
one is a solo Star Wars movie - there
seems to be if anything the aesthetic of
this looks similar to that solo spin-off
movie which might be intentional and the
thing that I like about the spin-off
idea is that each one seems like it's
gonna be allowed to add sort of its own
flavor to the unity not too much yeah
what happened here but still I got a
sort of unique vibe off of this like
it's gonna expand Star Wars out a little
bit I guess in in terms of the Canon
this is a period piece so that's fun I
mean also seeing the cast members
they're excited to see the whole trailer
tomorrow and even seeing a shot at
Donald Glover as Lando was like you know
what I am excited to see Donald Glover
and whatever he's doing I'm so surprised
I have total like 180 here that's part
of the fun of trailers sometimes is
especially now that we hear so much
about production yeah I'm the scenes
before you even seen an image the image
can change the whole thing yeah all
right guys though there's more Super
Bowl trailers to come but thanks for
letting us know that was out you can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification I'll get notified every
time one of our videos is up we'll see
you in a few minutes probably